on commence par notre bilan de campagne
tous les cinquante jours je vous donne
rendez vous pour ce décompte
présidentielle on verra si les tendances
anticipées par nos experts se confirme
on fera un petit bilan comme ça tous les
50 jours pour démarrer il faut forcément
analyser le phénomène politico
médiatique de ces dernières semaines
vous savez qui m'a oui forcément jérôme
rabier
il fait durer le plaisir pas encore
candidat eric zemmour attire déjà tous
les regards médiatiques d'abord commis
hier lors d'un débat avec le philosophe
michel onfray ou le polémiste a encore
donné sa vision de l'élection
présidentielle française ce n'est pas le
régime des partis et que vous connaissez
la formule célèbre c'est la rencontre
entre un homme et un peuple donc je
pense que nous sommes et je suis dans la
halle pure logique de la 5ème république
et de ce qu'a voulu le général de gaulle
désormais mesurée à plus de 12 % dans
les sondages eric zemmour est scruté par
tous ses adversaires en particulier la
droite traditionnelle et le
rassemblement national à qui il prend
des voix partisan d'une participation du
polémiste à la primaire de la droite le
sénateur l ère du rhône etienne blanc
estime que désormais la droite doit
s'emparer des thématiques développées
par eric zemmour ses idées
devrait assembler je crois pas que ce
soit un diviseur moi je crois à la
politique quand elle porte des idées des
convictions et bien je pense que les
élèves auraient tout intérêt à
comprendre ce qui est en train de se
passer et je crois que la recomposition
je parle des idées n'est pas terminée
certains à droite pourrait même être
tentés de choisir le polémiste comme
candidat s'il se lançait en fonction
aussi du champion que la droite se
choisira en congrès de s'exprimer a déjà
à plusieurs reprises sur
l'intérêt que je trouvais à une
candidature qui est virtuel pour
l'instant qui hors système erp pour
incarner car je mets les idées avant les
hommes n'appartient à aucune écurie
comme à l'époque emmanuel macron qui
avait fracturé le ps puis les l'ère eric
zemmour joue les trouble fête cette fois
ci pour les l'air comme le rassemblement
national et à 200 jours du second tour
de l'élection présidentielle sans même
s'être déclaré il occupe le devant de la
scène politico médiatique
reste à savoir si le phénomène va durer
j moins 200 ont des bas avec nos experts
je vous présente pascal perrineau
bonsoir politologue professeur à
sciences po paris ancien directeur du
cevipof jérôme sainte-marie bonsoir pour
soir meilleur de l'institut d'études et
de conseil pôle inbox vous publiez bloc
contre bloc la dynamique du maquereau
nisme c'est aux éditions du cerf florent
radio bonsoir soit président du team
tant que les terry docteur en sciences
politiques professeur à sciences po et
lætitia cuba notre éditorialiste des
mardis et jeudis en alternance avec
matthieu croissandeau bonsoir et
bienvenue
laetitia évidemment on commence par le
phénomène eric zemmour réaction
reportage de jérôme rabin c'est
intéressant d'entendre ces
parlementaires aient l'air pascal
perrineau il ya à quel point la
tentation zemmour est en train de gagner
du terrain si vous voulez ça tient au
fait que la droite classique et en
particulier élèves ont choisi de se
prononcer sur leur candidat traita
normalement le 4 décembre sur la
procédure ils ont mis tout l'été à se
décider et ils ont choisi la procédure
des primaires fermées extrêmement tard
le calendrier donc un calendrier
extrêmement longs pendants lesquelles
dans cette pré campagne
il n'y a pas de candidat de la droite
classique et donc l'espace politique
ayant horreur du vide il est occupé
alors il a été occupé en effet par
marine le pen nicolas dupont aignan il a
été occupé et il est occupé par le
candidat macron le président-candidat
macron quand on regarde les lectorats
tout de même le gros problème de what
c'est que tous les candidats de droite
sans exception ne parviennent pas à
rassembler derrière eux plus de 50% de
l'électorat fillon donc il y a une un
combat j'allais dire entre emmanuel
macron et le ou la candidate de droite
qui est absolument extraordinaire donc
en cette absence eh bien c'est la meteor
la météo revenue l'extérieur zemmour qui
occupent l'espace phoenix la durée avec
cet attentat bien sûr la tentation
zemmour tant qu'il n'y aura pas un
candidat de droite classique clairement
désigné qui occupera l'espace c'est à
dire qu'il y à encore devant nous tout
le mois d'octobre est tout le mois de
novembre alors on va regarder quelques
intentions de vote on a choisi le
sondage ifop fiducial pour le figaro et
lci qui donne alors j'ai donné quatre
premiers dans cette partie là on verra
les candidats de la gauche après lens
est donc les macarons et à 24 marine le
pen à 18 janvier bertrand à 15 eric
zemmour à 12 jérôme sainte-marie à
d'autres sondages qui donnent eric
zemmour devant
xavier bertrand c'est alors
très très peu de
d'intentions de vote mais quand même oui
et des deux très grandes fluctuations
entre les instituts de sondage dans
cette période alors c'est tout à fait
normal et légitime dans la mesure où
l'opinion n'est pas fixée vous savez il
ya un chiffre très important à retenir
c'est dans le dernier sondage opinionway
46% des français seulement déclarent
s'intéresser à la campagne électorale il
ya vingt points de différence dans cet
intérêt déclarée entre les hommes et les
femmes il y à 20 points de différence
entre les csp + il est 16 p moi grosso
modo plus on a inclus plus on est âgé
plus diplômés et plus on se déclare
s'intéresser à la campagne tant et si
bien que lorsque vous établissez les
intentions de vote si vous décidez vous
savez en maintenant au fonctionne
essentiellement par une note de 0 à 10
en fonction d'un certitude d'aller voter
si on choisit uniquement la note 10 donc
est plus certain on n'a que 50 % du
corps électoral tel cas d'ipsos a
récemment et alors ça peut être légitime
tout aussi bien que de choisir la note 8
9 et 10 mai du coup on n'a pas tout à
fait la même population et on n'a pas
tout à fait les mêmes résultats il n'y a
pas à mon sens soyons très clairs en
tant que sondeurs je suis pas sûr qu'ils
aient un bon choix actuellement mais
c'est tout à fait légitime que les
méthodes soient différentes selon les
instituts mais ça arrive ça révèle cette
fluctuation qu'on n'est pas qu'on est
comme un rat et je te dirai que ses
intentions de vote sont à peine des
intentions de vote plutôt sont les
intentions de vote pour une partie notre
échantillon et des préférences de vote
sur un choix hypothétique est couvert à
l'instant par une bonne partie de
l'échantillon et pourtant c'est à partir
de cette matière politique qui est le
sondage quand même que la candidature et
moins elle elle commence à fracturer
au sein de l air mais aussi au sein de
du parti de marine le pen n'est pas
neutre il m'est arrivé de dire et
d'écrire ça peut-être m'aider pour
autant que sondeurs mais de là à
l'occasion d'autres élections jamais les
sondages d'intentions de vote nos hôtes
en influence politique qu'au moment où
ils ont le moins de réalité c'est à dire
qu'effectivement ça joue très fortement
sur l'offre finale sur la désignation
alors même qu'on interroge des gens qui
encore une fois sont très diversement
motivé de ce fait vous avez également
une sociologie de l'intérêt comme je
soulignais de ce fait les catégories
populaires qui vont se réveiller
probablement en janvier février ce qui
provoquera des fluctuations comme très
souvent et bien de ce fait on aura
comment dirais-je là que pour l'instant
le choix se fait sur une certaine france
souvenons nous toujours quand nous
parlons de ces choses-là de ce qui
s'était passé en 1994 et 1995 donc c'est
un peu anciens je m'en excuse à
l'occasion du match dans le même concept
fossier aussi entre chirac et balladur
effectivement les sondages de 200 jours
avant le la présidentielle avait
sérieusement été remis en cause francs
radio c'est le paradoxe zemmour quand
même il est il est omniprésent mais il
n'est pas encore candidat ça le sert
cette espèce de d'ambiguïté mais pour
l'instant l'ensemble de sa montée en
puissance
bénéficier de cette ambiguïté puisque la
décision du csa lui a permis de se
victimiser au moment où c'était précieux
à sa montée en puissance et où de toute
façon il aurait plafonné dans sa
stratégie médiatique à force de faire
les de répéter les mêmes choses sur les
mêmes plateaux et puis effectivement on
ne sort de l'ambiguïté qu'à ses dépens
en disait françois mitterrand
visiblement eric zemmour n'est pas que
le l'héritier du général de gaulle
puisque il veut garder son oui mais j'en
ai entendu il veut garder cette
ambiguïté même si dans ses dernières
déclarations il commence de plus en plus
à le lever le voile et à acheminer
l'ensemble de ses soutiens vers une
candidature candidature qu'il justifie
par l'élan populaire qu'il constate à
chacun de ses déplacements donc c'est
assez amusant mais quand on regarde
d'ailleurs l'ensemble des
présidentielles on a toujours un
candidat trouble fête qui avant le mois
de janvier vient bousculer vient faire
peur aux partis traditionnels lui à
faire peur aux candidats et je crois que
ça a surtout un intérêt pour les autres
candidats parce que ça les oblige à se
positionner sur des thématiques de
campagne qu'ils vont devoir ensuite
récupérer et on le voit l'entrée
tonitruante de xavier bertrand sur les
sujets régaliens et n'a pas été
suffisante et il ne permet pas de
récupérer l'ensemble de l'électorat
fillon donc c'est où ça ça on voit aussi
des signaux sur comment rassembler son
camp sur quelles thématiques d'ici le
mois de janvier où je pense que on aura
une des écuries beaucoup plus stabilisée
et bien plus définitif que jusqu'à
présent oui parce que la candidature
zemmour évidemment
si elle intervient ou pas ça va impacter
la stratégie de tout le monde la
stratégie de marine le pen à stratégie
xavier bertrand ou de valérie pécresse
il dit ils sont en attente en quelque
sorte mais pour plusieurs raisons
d'abord parce qu'il ya une stratégie en
termes rhétorique en termes de
thématiques de campagne on le voit pour
l'instant c'est plutôt lui qui arrive à
mettre à l'agenda du siège effet la
jungle et puis l'après la candidature
est une candidature éventuellement haute
à baissent mécaniquement le seuil
d'accès au second tour et donc quelque
part il peut rebattre les cartes en
créant des proximités entre le candidat
de la droite républicaine
marine le pen alors on voit quand même
que emmanuel macron caracol de manière
assez constante dans les sondages donc
la question on a quasiment un des
finalistes emmanuel macron la question
qui se pose c'est qui chutera sur
l'obstacle zemmour un peu comme qui a
chuté sur l'obstacle chevènement en 2002
par exemple laetitia vous avez analysé
la tentation du clown dans dans un livre
publié récemment chez cannes éditeurs
déjà buchet chastel duché chastel merci
je l'avais oublié est ce qui prend au
donald trump très clairement pour
modèles dans cette campagne oui c'est ce
que j'allais vous vous répondre monsieur
c'est que nous ne sommes plus en 2002
nous sommes vingt ans plus tard et
qu'est ce qui a changé par rapport à
2002 c'est la révolution numérique ça
n'a échappé à personne moi je les mêmes
sur le plateau on est trois à l'avoir
sur le bateau d'un téléphone portable ce
qui donne une horizontalité de la
société qu'on le veuille ou non c'est à
dire que je vaux jérôme sainte-marie
comme je vous vous thomas or dans les
faits ce n'est pas vrai et trump a surfé
sur ce tout se vaut et eric zemmour a
évidemment donald trump comme modèle
absolu dans sa campagne et pour preuve
je vous propose de réécouter une de ses
chroniques quand il était encore que
journaliste que journaliste voilà il
était sûr au figaro et sur rtl là
précisément c'est sur rtl c'était en
janvier 2018 écouter ce qu'ils disent
est sûre la présidence trump parce qu'il
subit l'opposition inédite d'une sorte
de triangle des bermudes d'une puissance
exceptionnelle médias hollywood et
silicon valley à washington même le
président doit tenir compte des
résistances d'une élite administratives
policières diplomatique judiciaire
financière qui considère que même les
luttes du peuple ne doit pas conduire
une politique contraire à ses propres
convictions c'est ce qu'on appelle
l'état profond qu'ils exercent sur le
président des pressions permanentes
allant jusqu'au chantage face au risque
d'enfermement le président ne conserve
qu'une parade mais très efficace sa
parole ses discours ses tweets dont il
fait un usage compulsif il agit en fait
comme un chef de l'opposition en exil
mais c'est un peu ce qu'il est cela lui
permet de poursuivre le combat
idéologique et de conserver le contact
avec son électorat populaire
pourrait-on appliquer ce que vient dire
eric zemmour en 2018 à sa stratégie
d'aujourd'hui je vous réponds oui donc
évidemment que cette opposition entre
l'état profond et l'élu du peuple choisi
par le peuple va être un peu au coeur de
sa stratégie
comme on est en france bien sûr il
adapta au modèle français au modèle
culturel français et lui se pose en
homme censure et bâillonné par un
système qui serait pro macro gauche
caviar un peu monopolisé par des médias
de la bien pensante on le connaît un
tout le verbatim donc ce alors qu'il est
omniprésent mais bon on est d'accord
mais vous voyez bien que le parallèle
avec donald trump est vraiment on peut
le tracé du début à la fin et pour
l'opérationnel a pour l'opérationnel
c'est la même chose puisque le but est
le même le but c'est de fédérer une
communauté des lecteurs au delà des
classes sociales et des origines
géographiques et aussi certainement
quand je vous écoute de faire venir aux
urnes ce qu'avait réussi donald trump
les abstentionnistes et donc les moyens
quels sont ils ce donald trump
certainement la parole directe la parole
libérée lisait eric zemmour est
évidemment tout tout la larme on va dire
de communication massive d'armes fatales
c'est à dire les réseaux sociaux le
numérique les plateformes et comme par
hasard eric zemmour qui était
complètement allergiques 1 jusqu'en
avril il n'était surpris à aucun réseau
social rien mais depuis avril ils
postent quasiment une story instagram
par jour c'est un peu une caricature
mais on en est là c'est à dire que c'est
exactement le même but que donald trump
s'est encore une fois de faire campagne
en parallèle alors c'est intéressant
parce que le débat qu'il a veillé avec
michel onfray il devait être diffusée
sur facebook il ya pas de mondial de
facebook c'est pas de chance ce sont des
choses qui arrivent florent va dire où
vous connaissez bien vous analyser les
mutations de la numérisation de
l'économie vous voyez un peu tiqué à
certains ça s'appelle de la chronique de
laëtitia pourquoi oui parce qu'en fait
la socialisation politique via les
réseaux sociaux elle est quand même très
frappé d'un contexte culturel il a lâché
1 gouvernance digital et souveraineté de
sciences po a publié une étude sur
justement comment les populistes ce
informe-t-il j'aime bien quel réseau et
en voix qui a quand même des différences
qui sont très importantes selon les
nations et selon aussi les communautés
structuré c'est à dire qu'il ya une
audience extrêmement structurée sur des
communautés mobiliser qu'on peut
effectivement
actionné en france mais qui sont de
moindre importance on n'est pas sur des
phénomènes à la baule sonar aux essais
chez sa chaîne twitter moi je crois
aussi que quand on regarde sur les
campagnes politiques des municipales des
cantonales des choses qui vraiment
touche la france qui votent
twitter est quasiment absent parce que
on a globalement 5 % de la population et
susurre en dehors de paris des gens qui
sont extrêmement pas
beaucoup plus présent mais avec une
stratégie médiatique d'entrisme
médiatique qui visiblement pour moi est
hors de portée pour l'instant des
équipes d'eric zemmour ça demande une
masse critique beaucoup plus importante
mais peut-être que la campagne me
démentir ce cas une hypothèse aussi
qu'il veut que l'on peut faire une
campagne très massives dans les derniers
temps et que ça peut fonctionner juste
avant le vote et justement les réseaux
sociaux servent à ça puisque il accélère
tout pour le marketing politique
finalement pour cibler directement les
électeurs sur encore une fois nos
téléphones et les ordinateurs mais vous
dites qu'il faut des outils
puissant et qui les a pas forcément
c'est intéressant jérôme sainte-marie
sur sur le parallèle trump zemmour
oui non c'est simplement chercher je
voulais juste noté en sait un peu
périphériques 1 par rapport à notre
conversation c'est que il utilise le mot
état profond eric zemmour de manière
erronée c'est à dire que l'état profond
c'est pas ça du tout là il confond en
fait ce qui suscite beaucoup gramsci
mais je pas sûr qu'il était totalement
lui parce que il confond la notion
d'état profonde émotion data intégrale
chez gramsci mais l'état intégrale chez
gucci ça veut dire les classes
dominantes grosso modo l'état profond ça
signifierait plus tôt
comment dirais-je les structure
décisionnaire au sein de la haute
administration on va dire ça comme ça
mais ils vont bref mais c'est pas assez
pas fondamental effectivement c'est une
situation ils essayent de se victimiser
comme cela alors que je ne suis pas sûr
qu'au sein des catégories dominante et
bien qu'il soit que la solution zemmour
soit tellement décriée au fond c'est le
permet de récupérer des thématiques
assez populaire et des thématiques
étaient très fréquemment utilisé au sein
dlr d'ailleurs et pour justement avoir
un promouvoir un modèle de société qui
est bart bien des côtés assez
conservateur en tout cas qui est sur les
problématiques qu'on n'a pas eu tout à
aborder qu'on va aborder je crois que
vous allez aborder tout à l'heure dans
l'émission les problématiques et
sociales notamment sont pour l'instant
très absente de son discours or même si
il faut bien voir le pouvoir d'achat
aujourd'hui la priorité des français par
rapport à la campagne l'immigration est
un sujet qui touche à plein d'autres
c'est un sujet total en quelque sorte
mais c'est quand même un des sujets ce
n'est pas le principal et il peut
rassembler 2 français sur 3 sur ses
propos aujourd'hui
enfin quoique non sur la réprobation des
migrations il peut rassembler 2 français
sur 3 sur ces propositions c'est
beaucoup moins vrai oui on avait vu que
c'était le le candidat le plus détesté
aussi j'ai été sondé ça vous partez du
principe qu'on va voter selon les
programmes et les positions et de les
gens tout à fait moi il me semble que
non justement et la force de zemmour et
c'est steve bayonne qui avait impulsé ça
aux états unis c'est qui va jouer sur
l'affect le ressenti non la colère et le
sentiment d'y assurer un autre thème
dans ton dont on
vous mouiller un petit peu parce qu'on
se retrouvera dans 50 ans sera candidat
écoutez la probabilité qu'il soit
candidat et certainement élever disons
ça comme ça
cependant si vous voulez les états unis
c'est pas la france
et eric zemmour par rapport à trump qui
a une très grande différence c'est que
trump avait pendant des mois ferrailler
pour contrôler un des deux grands
appareils de la vie politique américaine
les républicains et que contre
l'establishment républicain il avait
réussi à avoir le parti derrière lui
eric zemmour est bien loin de ceux là et
ça m'étonnerait que en dépit de quelques
réactions de sénateur elle est ça
m'étonnerait que l air sauf
à eric zemmour ça c'est la première
chose la deuxième chose c'est quand vous
regardez aujourd'hui dans les enquêtes
d'opinion la base sociale de eric
zemmour c'est une base très bourgeoise
et couches moyennes et personnes âgées
c'est à dire qu'il est très très loin un
de pénétrer ces milieux de des couches
populaires blanche que le candidat trump
avait vu avaient pu pénétrer donc pour
l'instant si vous voulez il faut ramener
tout de même eric zemmour à sa juste
proportion il turbul en effet si l'on
prend les les résultats de l'ifop 12%
c'est tout à fait significatif il
abaisse en effet le seuil d'entrée au
premier tour mais attention en abaissant
le seuil d'entrée au premier tour les
courbes du candidat de la droite
classique et du candidat de la droite
extrême peuvent se croiser donc quelque
part il pourrait rendre indirectement
services voyaient à quelqu'un comme
valérie pécresse
ou
xavier bertrand on suivra ça est
vraiment d'un mot y sera candidat je
suis prêt à parier hockey jérôme sainte
marie ah oui oui oui chaque pas bon bah
écoute et on en reparlera dans 50 jours
je pense qu'effectivement il ya un mois
je le pense aussi
l'unité va
prépare une surprise tiens je vous
propose parce que c'est une leçon
d'humilité aussi merci de jouer le jeu
mais si on regarde les sondages qui
était donné à peu près de 100 jours
avant la présidentielle il ya quelques
années alors on commence par quoi parce
que j'y vois pas très bien là sur
l'écran on commence mar 2010 et 2011
donc on à françois hollande qui est
devant nicolas sarkozy et marine le pen
ça pour le coup ça a été ça a été
confirmé par le scrutin si on avance en
2010 est évidemment là c'est plus
compliqué puisque dans ce sondage qui
était également autour de 200 jours on a
notamment un alain juppé qui a explosé
en vol par bande être un peu triviale
emmanuel macron seulement en 3e position
donc voilà on sait c'est ce qu'on a dit
jérôme sainte-marie vous avez fait vous
même preuve de
kiel s'est pas présenté donc vous avez
ans françois hollande qui ne s'est pas
planté une envie bien sûr c'est un
groupe et c'est pour ça que je dis on a
été unanime sur le la candidature
zemmour on verra bien j'aimerais qu'on
parle maintenant de d'anne hidalgo anne
hidalgo il ya le canard enchaîné qui qui
publie un avis de recherche dans son
édition à paraître demain avis de
recherche anne hidalgo avez vous des
nouvelles dalles hidalgo évidemment
c'est cruel mais c'est drôle aussi et ça
pose une vraie question depuis le
lancement de sa campagne c'était le
12 septembre on parlait de celui qui
imprime le calendrier elle fait pas
événements elle imprime pas le
calendrier il ya eu cette proposition
doubler le salaire des professeurs ou
des adultes en contact avec des élèves
dans le système éducatif mais au-delà de
ça il s'est pas passé grand-chose
faut-il un plan b pour le ps on va
écouter ce qu'en dit olivier faure le
premier secrétaire forcément il assure
que non
je suis comme tout le monde je regarde
les sondages parce que je vais vous
raconter d'histoires et quand on est
haut je suis plus content que quand on
est bien évidemment je regarde les
tendances ça m'intéresse mais je dis
attention aussi si vous voulez qu'on
arrête tout de suite on peut se dire
aussi l'élection présidentielle bat au
moins d'octobre on dit que le mieux
placé dans les sondages ce truc a gagné
voilà et donc à ce compte là et bien
aujourd'hui juppé serait président et
puis avant lui balladur l'aurait été
aujourd'hui olivier faur vous cherchez
pas de plan b à annie elle doit
absolument pas pourquoi un plan b pas de
plan b anne hidalgo est ce que vous
employez le terme fiasco pour qualifier
ce début de campagne florent radio
d'abord il n'est pas encore la candidate
du parti socialiste qu'elle sera désigné
le 14 octobre est donc de ce fait il ya
une fiction qui doit se maintenir et je
crois que la fiction pour les organismes
partisans elle a une vertu c'est qu'il
vaut mieux ne pas décevoir les
organismes partisans lorsqu'on sollicite
leur leur investiture ensuite il ya un
fiasco ça serait beaucoup dire parce que
honnêtement la forme la campagne n'a pas
commencé il ya une forme de patinage
et j'ai envie de dire c'est assez normal
parce que jusqu'à il ya peu de temps
elle n'avait pas d'adversaire à gauche
hormis jean luc mélenchon on ne savait
pas si c'était yannick jadot qui serait
candidat ou sandrine rousseau ce qui est
quand même en termes de positionnement
politique en termes de capital de voix
change considérablement la donne et de
ne pas forcément une bonne nouvelle ça
dépendra très clairement des thèmes de
campagne pour lesquels elle optera terre
que s'il s'agit de concurrencer yannick
jadot sur l'écologie quand on fait une
campagne écologiste on appelle à voter
écologistes et on préfère toujours
l'original à la copie
quand bien même les opinions politiques
sont extrêmement ancrée donc il faudra
de ce fait et on l'a vu sur les
élections européennes par exemple avec
raphaël glucksmann il faut une pause il
un positionnement qui permet de faire un
électorat socialiste socle qui existent
en france il entre 6 et 9% donc déjà ça
permet d'entrer dans une dynamique de
campagne différente si on a un socle de
10% en entrée de campagne en janvier ça
augure d'une capacité de progression
différentes donc moi je ne suis pas
critique pour l'instance il faut un
positionnement vis-à-vis de yannick
jadot il faut une entrée en campagne
qu'ils soient effectivement plus marquée
sur des thématiques pour avoir rassemblé
son électorat mais je crois que rien
n'est joué d'avancé elle est absente
mais médiatiquement contre lui non c'est
très étrange je vais vous dire parce que
tout de même elle commence par lancer
une bombe dans le débat public vous
rendez compte doubler le salaire des
professeurs là on comprend la base du
parti socialiste il ya beaucoup beaucoup
d'enseignants du primaire du secondaire
du supérieur donc voilà et ensuite
silence radio quand on lance une telle
bombe il faut argumenter argumenté en
particulier autour de la question des
moyens à dégager pour satisfaire le
service après vente et le service après
vente et là pas du tout service
après-vente j'avoue que moi ça m'a
plongé dans une perplexité totale parce
que c'était vraiment pas à la hauteur de
l'effet d'annoncé et est tonitruant vous
souvenez quand c'est tombé et d'ailleurs
les principales réactions sont venus
presque de son camp c'est à dire de la
gauche ont dix ans mais tout de même
elle ose mais enfin c'est pas possible
vous avez vu montebourg etc
donc jean luc mélenchon se dit est-ce
que le ps est encore un parti de
gouvernement aux frênes attendu ça coûte
beaucoup trop cher c'est donc une
stratégie tout de même très très
étonnante et puis maintenant il ya tout
de même la course poursuite pour le
leadership de ce qui reste de la gauche
comment dire de gouvernement non
protestataires et là on voit bien que la
victoire qui n'était pas évidente la
victoire de yannick jadot rend la tâche
de anne hidalgo beaucoup plus difficile
pour le combat pour le leadership c'est
vrai qu objectivement aujourd'hui
yannick jadot est beaucoup mieux placé
c'était pas évident encore il ya
quelques semaines un est beaucoup mieux
placé que anne hidalgo pour prétendre à
ce leadership mais il l'est parce que
elle fait preuve de faiblesse ou
d'absence ou etc oui parce qu'il n'y a
pas eu non plus et non on va parler des
verts dans un instant mais n'a pas non
plus eu de nom beaucoup de propositions
de yannick jadot qui ont marqué le
calendrier se parle du calendrier le jeu
mais je fais pas sur l'or mais qu'on
marque
il avait une affaire interne important
c'est pas fun à gérer bon il s'est tout
même remarquablement bien débrouillé
parce que sur le papier ils étaient tous
même battu donc voilà et on maîtrise mal
aujourd'hui au fond le comportement de
ces hommes et de ces femmes qui se
déplace dans les primaires on a beaucoup
de mal à prévoir leur comportement et et
on va de parfois de surprise de surprise
en surprise mais moi ce qui me frappe
aussi c'est quand on regarde les
soutiens de anne hidalgo d'abord il ya
il ya un problème c'est que anne hidalgo
et maire de paris mais au fond elle ne
joue pas le réseau important des maires
socialistes en région les maires
socialistes en région je pense à la
maire de nantes à la maire de rennes etc
c'est une réalité et je président de
région voilà un je ne comprends pas
qu'elle reste incroyablement parisienne
et ça se voit dans ses soutiens c'est
paris ile de france et dès que vous
quittez le périphérique au sens large et
bien c'est une candidate marginales
alors on va regarder avant je vous donne
la parole aux saintes maries sondage
ifop fiducial pour le figaro lci est
donc là on est sur les candidats de
gauche avec un ami jadot entre 8 et 9
jean luc mélenchon entre 7 et 8 anne
hidalgo donc cinq et demi 6 arnaud
montebourg entre 3 et 4 et fabien
roussel entre a et demi et deux ennemis
se sortent des faiblard pour l'instant
dans les sondages mais comme des fleurs
on va dire on n'est pas elle elle
remplit pas sa sa salle en quelque sorte
oui c'est intéressant parce que il faut
bien noter quand même que la gauche le
parent socialistes sont très bien sortis
des élections municipales les élections
départementales des élections régionales
le nouveau clivage entre progressistes
et populistes ne s'impose pas du tout au
niveau local dont il ya deux clivages
qui existent en quelque sorte qu'ils
organisent ou plutôt qui désorganise la
vie politique dans france actuellement
je pense qu'un et galgo c'est un propos
un peu polémique mais et le point
d'aboutissement du monde approche d'un
long processus de dépolitisation du
parti socialiste vous savez il ya un
congrès ya pas longtemps on a à peine
parler de départ socialiste autrefois
c'était d'émotion c'était des êtres et
théâtre et théâtralisée on ressortait
souvent des arguments idéologiques pour
cacher des luttes de pouvoir personnel
mais alors là aujourd'hui plus du tout
et plus du tout et puis c'est quoi cette
façon alors c'est aussi le fait c'est
peut-être que c'est la conséquence de ce
que je disais précédemment c'est à dire
que c'est avant tout désormais un cartel
d'élus il ya très peu de militants et du
coup les cartels et le fait d'être un
élu local fondamentalement ça dépolitise
plutôt les choses vous avez
effectivement les différences d'ailleurs
c'est une des raisons de l'abstention
qui croit les différences de gestion
entre les présidents de départements de
gauche nos droits tous les maires de
gauche de droite aujourd'hui les budgets
sont allemands contre un étalement de
dépenses obligées en quelque sorte que
vous avez très peu de variation si tant
est si bien que le spectacle est plutôt
fait lors des élections à lui et lection
présidentielle par des gens comme jean
luc mélenchon qui ont très peu pour
seulement qu'on puisse dire de présence
au niveau local et qui sont donc
extrêmement libre dans leurs propos
laetitia me semble que en fait anne
hidalgo est absente médiatiquement parce
qu'elle ne fait pas l'événement vous
savez bien que les médias viennent quand
vous proposer quelque chose à filmer ou
à raconter
et voilà donc il faut faire l'événement
soit avec une idée soit avec un
déplacement et pourquoi le parti
socialiste est faible parce que il n'a
fait aucune proposition en pendant ces
cinq ans il était dans l'opposition
olivier faure est une incarnation très
faible olivier port je ne sais pas si en
sortant la dans la rue tout le monde
sait qui il est malheureusement alors
qu' il est le leader du parti socialiste
c'est un parti d'opposition direct à
emmanuel macron comme les télés l air
emmanuel macron a profité de
l'atomisation de l'échiquier politique
mais je pense que c'est quand même un
peu trop lui donner que de dire c'est à
cause d' emmanuel macron qu'on en est
arrivé là non un moment il faut aussi
prendre ses responsabilités quand on est
dans les deux camps des partis
historiques de gouvernement et se rendre
compte qu'effectivement les propositions
sont quasiment nulles emmanuel macron
quête au second tour dans tous les
instituts de sondage donnent samba et
qu'est ce qui pourrait le faire dévisser
ou est-ce qu'il a un soc finalement qui
me semble très solide non moi je vais
essayer d'écrire quelques façons socle
saisir ce que j'ai appelé le bloc
élitaire c'est à dire une bonne partie
des vraies élites les cadres supérieurs
qui ont largement abandonnée pour ceux
du privé la droite pour ceux du public
la gauche ça ça se maintient
sondage après sondage élection après
élection est une bonne partie des
retraités qui alors ils sont pas
toujours très content mais quand même
ils ont pu voir l'occasion du covin 19 à
quel point leur intérêt déjà sanitaires
et leurs intérêts financiers étaient
garantis par le chef de l'état il faut
bien voir que emmanuel macron ressort
très con forte de la crise du coc vide
19 en janvier 2020 on était en pleine
polémique sur et manifestations sur la
réforme des retraites et il est sorti de
là il était donc été assez peu populaire
en fait et aujourd'hui il est certes
impopulaire mais comment ne pas être
impopulaire dans la france d'aujourd'hui
donc il a effectivement un socle très
puissant il bénéficie également sur des
cp s'explique un petit peu les problèmes
de madame hidalgo en dehors de sa
personnalité ou de sa communication
c'est qu'une bonne partie des
sympathisants socialistes comme une
bonne partie des sympathisants et l'air
ont une bonne opinion de l'exécutif font
confiance au président de la république
sondage après sondage vous voyez 30 t'as
40 % parfois en période de crise
davantage des sympathisants de la gauche
de gouvernement ou la droite de
gouvernement libre et ça parce que donc
ce ne sont pas des vrais souvent c'est
que si il est quand même plus perçu
comme un président des riches et qu'il a
du mal à marcher et qui librement non
non ce que l'on constate quand vous
parler avec des gens de gauche c'est
qu'ils sont persuadés que c'est un
président de droite mais quand vous
parlez des gens de droite sont persuadés
que c'est un président de gauche moi
j'ai tendance à prendre au sérieux les
belles et enfin à être un peu comment
dire et formaliste quelqu'un qui me dit
qu'il est de gauche et ans à penser
qu'il est de gauche rien qui me dit
qu'il est ni droite ni gauche tendance à
penser que c'est vrai en tout cas dans
ses soutiens c'est vrai je rappellerai
que ce problème date du tout début du
quinquennat le 4 juillet 2010 est à
l'assemblée nationale deux parties qui
venait de se retrouver dans l'opposition
les a l'air d'un côté les socialistes
deux doigts de l'autre les deux tiers
les trois quarts par dont les trois
quarts de leurs députés présents et bien
ce sont tout simplement abstenus dès le
départ on ne savait pas si les temps
l'app store dans l'opposition pas un mot
sur emmanuel macron flan vanille et puis
ensuite on on s'intéresse évidemment à
yannick jadot et europe ecologie les
verts brossé on l'a déjà dit et ça
semble un peu une évidence mais je pense
qu'il faut le rappeler sont intéressés
d'entrer en campagne le plus tard
possible oui en tout cas de se déclarer
candidat will be tard possible et
présenté comme un président candidat
effectivement l'entrée en campagne elle
a déjà redémarré pour moi le 12 juillet
lors de son discours lorsqu'il a annoncé
l'obligation vaccinale qui n'en est pas
une et lorsqu'il l'a fait je crois 25
minutes sur le contexte sanitaire est
quasiment 25 minutes sur en gros la
société de demain les quelques pistes
qu'il commençait annoncé plus son tour
de france donc il est candidat avec un
rétablissement absolument extraordinaire
parce qu'effectivement il sortait
égratigné de la crise et gilet jaune le
début de la crise sanitaire a été quand
même une catastrophe gestionnaire
absolue et avec l'arrivée du vaccin avec
la capacité de gérer la rouverture avec
le plan de relance avec l'argent avec
l'argent qui a été déversé sur une
partie des secteurs avec continuent
d'être des vies monde avec des mesures
catégorielles qui vit qui voit le jour
la taxe d'habitation les gens peuvent le
constater en ce moment même certains en
sont exemptés tout ça constitue un
capital de campagne assez important et
puis il ya des réflexions qui revient
très souvent chez les gens c'est qu'ils
à sa place auraient fait mieux et
finalement il ya aussi cet exercice de
comparaison
et quand on regarde effectivement qui se
présente face à lui eh bien ils gardent
une stature présidentielle et il est
crédité d'avoir tenu le pays alors que
certains on estime qu'il serait en peine
pour le tenir allez on termine avec les
verts yannick jadot depuis le 28
septembre c'est donc le candidat désigné
après une courte victoire 2110 voix
d'avancé qui font rage et sandrine
rousseau elle fait entendre sa
différence depuis mai mais pour julien
bayou le secrétaire national du parti
tout va bien
on a besoin de radicalité dans une
écologie de gouvernement s'ils voulaient
si c'est pour avoir des filets d'eau
tiède comme le gouvernement actuel ça ne
sert à rien comme dirait great attenberg
c'est du blabla sandrine rousseau a su
faire venir à la politique des gens qui
disaient je fais de la politique quand
vous êtes féministe c'est politique
évidemment les droits des femmes c'est
politique mais je me tiens à l'écart des
partis et donc je crois qu'on doit aussi
réussir ça dans la campagne à l'égard de
notamment de la jeunesse vous avez une
grande partie du nouveau climat qui dit
mas n'y a pas plus politique que le
climat a puisqu'il s'agit des
générations présentes et de l'avenir de
générations futures mais elles disent je
me suis je me tiens loin des
organisations partisanes et bien tout
l'enjeu notre campagne et j'en ai
discuté beaucoup avec eni jadot nous
voulons permettre que cette énergie
cette envie cette soif de justice elle
puisse s'exprimer dans la présidentielle
tout en gardant cette indépendance à
l'égard des partis yannick jadot
sandrine rousseau pascal perrineau est
ce que c'est la synthèse impossible
écoutez la synthèse est difficile heurte
au gabon tout le monde dit le contraire
bien sûr embrassons nous folleville mais
enfin c'est vraiment laborieux et la
manière dont après la victoire qui est
tout de même courte mais imparable de
yannick jadot la manière dont sandrine
rousseau a été mauvaise perdante a été
tout même tout à fait étonnante en train
de négocier comme un vieux radical
socialiste sous la troisième république
la quatrième république sa place dans le
dispositif de campagne bon voila il va
falloir on voit bien le chemin et le
chemin de croix peut-être que yannick
jadot aura à parcourir alors il faudra
aller au delà des synthèses facile
julien bayou la radicalité dans le
gouvernement le gouvernement dans la
radicalité on a la pression là aussi
d'une motion de fans congrès où on fait
croire aux françaises et aux français
n'importe quoi le problème ça va être
d'abord de rassembler son camp mais elle
les écologistes voilà dans une
présidentielle ça n'a jamais fait plus
de 5 6 % là où le crédite de 9% bon il
faut tout même qu'il solidifie
maintenant ce camp écologiste qui aurait
pu aller voir ailleurs vers la
radicalité mélenchon ouvert emmanuel
macron un leurs représentants au fond
tout à fait mais après ce qu'on a dit en
effet voilà bon donc ça c'est un
problème puis ensuite bien sûr il faut
qu'ils rassemblent ce qui reste du
peuple de gauche alors parce que s'il
veut peser il faut qu'il aille bien au
delà de son bassin naturel d'électeurs
écologistes même élargi alors c'est vrai
que le peuple de gauche aujourd'hui
quand vous faites le total vous arrivez
à du 25 28 % des suffrages exhaure mais
voilà mais s'il veut éventuellement
pouvoir
laisser penser à l'électorat qui
pourrait s'inviter dans un second tour
il va être obligé de rassembler ce
peuple de gauche et là il va falloir
trouver toute une série de thématiques
certes écologistes mais ça ne suffira
pas parce que la thématique économique
et sociale particulièrement du pouvoir
d'achat est extrêmement présente dans
l'ensemble de l'électorat mais surtout
dans l'état de bauchi on se mouille
yannick jadot au-delà des 10% est ce que
vous y croyez dans 50 jours
écoutez aux imperfections mais je suis
perplexe voyez pas décollé non mais bon
jérôme sainte marie oui un des problèmes
de l'écologie c'est que ça relève s'il
faut se munir de la permaculture la vie
politique écologiste dire c'est un tout
petit milieu très frotter en quelque
sorte de la vie universitaire vous savez
c'est un peu et qu à une sociologie
c'est ce qu'on appelait autrefois on
appelle ça les bobos maintenant si on
appelait ça autrefois du payeur plus
raisonnable la petite bourgeoisie de
diplômés urbaine et cetera et donc c'est
la permaculture et c'est le problème
c'est la permaculture comme vous le
savez c'est une culture hors sol en
quelque sorte est intense mais sur un
espace très limité et un rendement du
rendement mais c'est très intéressant
après c'est une pratique agricole tout à
caratère permaculture tout à fait
intéressant moi aussi d'ailleurs
mais en politique c'est moins rentable
si vous voulez et vous avez
effectivement c'est de mettre les
rendements agricoles comme n'ont pas les
mêmes réseaux son voisin portant tout
simplement parce que quand on
s'intéresse à cette population qui a ses
propres et préoccupations c'est tout à
fait légitime pour apporter un débat
interne et/ou une primaire eh bien on
s'éloigne du point d'équilibré la
société française on s'élève surtout des
attentes de ceux qui votaient
généralement pour la gauche pour leur
pouvoir d'achat pour l'heure les la
protection la protection sociale ce
genre de choses alors au delà de 10 ou
pas non je pense 150 jeunes restent en
dessous des 10 la radio ce qui est
intéressant c'est la victoire de yannick
jadot à la primaire alors certes on ne
maîtrise pas le corps électoral de la
primaire mais les verts ont fait mentir
leur réputation puisque d'ordinaire
s'est bien passé toujours le candidat
qui avait le plus de chances de perdre
c'était le cas d'eva joly face à un
nicolas hulot pour nous pour ne parler
que d'elle là j'ai l'impression que les
écologistes sont devenus un parti de
gouvernement et ça vaut d'ailleurs pour
julien bayou qui a troqué la tenue
d'étudiants pour celle du costume
chemise du chef de parti et le discours
du chef de parti et tout ça n'est pas
qu'anecdotique c'est que ils ont pris le
candidat qu'ils estiment être en mesure
de tenir le cap d'une présidentielle en
revanche est ce que cela élargit pour
autant leur socle électoral je ne le
crois pas ils ont un candidat qui
effectivement est un candidat qui peut
aller dans un gouvernement dans une
coalition gouvernementale
mais peut-il aller élargir le seigle le
cercle en dehors effectivement des
élites urbaines j'ai du mal à le croire
donc je plaide pour -2 9% au saut au
premier tour des présidents ont verra ça
dans 50 jours seraient vite laetitia en
deux secondes sauf si les jeunes se
décide à aller voter parce que pour
l'instant les jeunes sont
majoritairement
abstentionnistes si les jeunes vont aux
urnes je ne sais pas pour qui d'autre
mais dans 50 jours ils se sont peut-être
pas encore décidé donc vous mais là on
soit encore les dix ans
merci merci d'être vous êtes plier
finalement à l'exercice on se retrouve
dans 50 jours peut-être cours diffusera
quelques extraits tout à fait du débat à
léon